let's get into that oh man hey
we're calling out here really close to
covington
well man and covington that's my
hometown
where'd you do did you know i was from
somewhere raleigh
i did not know exactly where
well i am from covington louisiana do
you know what it's famous for
cheese oh wait that's wisconsin
yep nope it is famous for
tallest statue of ronald reagan in
america
tallest full copper statue of ronald
reagan
you have a favorite statue
can't say i do
you gotta have one man you should get
one i like uh i'll tell you a couple of
mine you're welcome to board if you need
but
there's one in um there was the tallest
bob hope statue and that was in uh
duran i believe it was duran illinois
can you look that up actually do you
mind really mel
um i hate to put you to work there but
you got to do something you know um
tallest bob hope statue peoria illinois
has a
richard pryor statue that i believe is
full pewter
or maybe 70 pewter or something and they
quit putting copper in a lot of statues
because a lot of homeless and
uh drug addicts or da's
will chip it out and uh
and sell it and smoke it
smoke uh drugs with the money
so you you know you do a copper statue
and then next you know it only has one
arm and they got you know 11 more
you know 11 more people smoking crack
near you
and you're just wondering how it all
financially made sense what do you have
a tallest bob hope statue
any information oh you wanted bob hope i
looked up the statue of hope
in uh friendship indiana
oh okay what is that it is
a private memorial or monument displayed
in a graveyard or cemetery
hope is one of the seven virtues of the
christian religion so it's literally
just about hope
oh that's beautiful not bob hope but
okay
well that's close enough man if if you
get that bob hope intel let us know
so yeah but i appreciate it fellow what
i'm telling you is down he called from
covington louisiana and that's
have the world's stall uh stall a statue
of ronald reagan and that's 10 feet tall
unprecedented ronald anyway uh thanks
for that call man riley male you got any
information on that uh
bob hope statue i do
so it says that bob hope may be
something of a forgotten figure as
a los angeles times writer said in a
november 29th story
about a new biography on late comedian
hope entertainer of the sun okay what
about the statue bubba
there is a nine foot five inch tall
fiberglass intimate
uh statue that has stood for 34 years
in uh rockford rockford illinois yes sir
wow
yeah man that's beautiful now something
this yes something you see different
places small towns like to do that
and like to honor something tall a
statue bob hope did he ever go see it
does it say
and there you go ladies and gentlemen
that's riley mao right there good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah